AoE,C-chança!
Look, I've got Square!
Yay!
Let's eat together!
You want to eat?
Chick-a-C-a-a-ice!
Other?
Chick-a-a-a-ice!
Choco-a-Ca-Ca-ice!
Other?
Choco-a-Ca-ice, and Choco-a-i-ice Mint-a-C-Ca-C-C-C-I...
Chick-a-C-C-C-A-ice...
Music
Morning, and chocolate mint And the daydreams and the
dessert Even the night of the day I'm happy to be happy It's
so delicious and it's so funny Why do I eat it?
I'll show you how it's so cute.
I'll teach it to you.
The blue, the fresh, the happy way to help you the God of
the world.
The sign of the call, the sign of the call.
The only one can understand the happiness of the world.
Oh, that's right, the Chokomi and Tokyo for the sake of the
world.
Mint, Mint, Mint, Mint, Mint, Choco Mint, ice, ice, ice,
Choco Mint, ice, ice, ice, ice, it's delicious, Choco Mint,
ice, ice, I love you, I love, love, love, love, I love, I
love you, I love, I love, Choco Mint, ice, ice, ice, more
one more Choco Mint, ice, ice, ice, I love, I love, ice,
Choco Mint, ice, ice, ice, I wish I knew.
Ayo-chan Ayo-chan
Me, Me, Me, Me, Me, Me, Me, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K,
K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K, K,
K, K, K K, K, K, K K K K, K, K K K K K, K, K K K, K, K K K K
K K, K K K, K K K K K K K K, K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K
K, K K K K K K K Because you're happy, you're happy, right?
See ya now See ya
now Aauk Aauk, a beautiful, Don't be Damasar Don't be Aaukmy
What are you making?
What are you?
Are you?
Is there a war?
What do you believe?
Chocominton is never stop!
Chocominton Ah!
Mito, chocominton Something was a lot of fun Chocominton,
ah!
What's it up?
Chocolate mint ice I could betterット Itadakina Chocolate mint
ice ice Dumb31, chocob mint ice ice Dumb choices so I eat it
Chocolate mint ice ice ice A-buckle mint ice With the words
and the words more than Done Ah I'm very happy, I'm a
co-wardian Ah, now I'm a More, thank you so much Chocolate
mint ice ice ice I'm so glad you've been here for a little
bit.
People are free and they choose what they choose.
I'm going to play a game.
Ah, ah, ah.
Ayu, I'm going to buy some candy.
Ayu, I'm going to buy some.
Say, Anna.
Let's eat some.
Chocolate mint or chocolate ice?
Chocolate ice!